ハジノリヌードル
ンフッ
めちゃくちゃかわいい
ありがとうございますっ！！
はい,みなさん2018年になったわけなんですけども
みなさん覚えてますか
僕
ラーメンを禁止していました
去年の1月の12日から
禁止しますって言ってたんで
今年の1月12日まで一応食べない予定です。
もう我慢できねぇや
うぅこれ2017年一回も食べなかったよ
えらいえらい
去年ラーメン屋さんで僕を見た人間は1人もいないでしょう
まぁ正直な感想
結構食べたくなるという欲求は
たまにはあったんですけど
そこまできつくなかったです
なんか別のたとえば
ハンバーガーとか牛丼とかで結構代用できたし
なんか苦しい局面ではあったんですけど
意外と（裏返った）
いけたのではないかなとな思っております
あと1週間くらいちょっと食べないように頑張ります
そこでなんですけども
今までの僕の禁止の
歴史をちょっとたどっていきましょう
2016年にお菓子を禁止しました
これがすごいつらかったの覚えてます
実際”おかし”食べないとなんか”おかし”くなっちゃう　こともあったんで
でジュースも飲めないわけでしょ？
結構もうメンタル的に不可能だなって思って
厳しい一年になりました
そして2017年
お菓子を失った僕はラーメンに目覚めてしまい
あほほどラーメン食った結果2017年にラーメンを禁止することになって
無事もうラーメン禁止が終わりそうなところでございます
さぁ！！！！！！！！
2018年
僕は
正直なんか禁止しなくてもいいんじゃねとか
思ったんですけど
なんか…
禁止するのが楽しくてさ
なんか禁止するのが楽しくてさ...///
なんか変な癖がついたわけでもないんですけどぉ
意外とね
禁止することによってなんか
見える何かっていうのがあるんですよ
僕はお菓子を禁止して
お菓子のあることの素晴らしさ幸せさを知って
ラーメンを禁止して
ラーメン以外にもおいしいものがたくさんあるって　　ことを
改めて確認出来て
さあ次何かを禁止しようって思ったときに
僕なに禁止すればいいのかなと思ったんですけど
僕は気づいてしまったんです
そういうわけじゃないんですけど
こう何かを我慢することによって
得られる何かっていうものが僕はあるってことはもう
気づいてるんで！！
今年も何かを禁止しようと思ってるわけなんですけども
今回!てか今年は！
僕がその今年禁止するものを
皆様に決めてもらおうと思います
僕が今年禁止すべきものをコメントで書いてください
で一つ忘れちゃいけないことが
僕はなぜ禁止をするかって理由ですね
お菓子にしろラーメンにしろ共通してることは
僕が　太らないようにするため
あと健康的な意味をこめて禁止していました
禁止するものは”ごはん”でお願いします
ごはん、ごはん系で
コメントたぶんどこかで動画で紹介すると思うので
そこはご了承ください
というわけでなんかご飯じゃなくてもべつにいいっす
まあ好きなもの書いちゃってください
まあとにかく僕がこの年禁止すべきものを書いてくれるとありがたいです。
それでなんかGOODの数とか見て
僕が判断して今年何を禁止するか決めようと思います
とりあえずみなさんに僕が何を禁止すべきかを
決めてください
アッ//　ドキドキしてきちゃった♡
とりあえずほんとに僕はラーメンが楽しみです
あと1週間で食えると思うんで
えーそれまで
1月10日くらいまでに書いててくれれば
まあありがたいなって感じです
皆さんコメントよろしくお願いします!!
じゃあな！